hello friends
um my name is bhargav and i'm here to
give a talk today on uh computational
social science with python
and uh how open source transforms
academia and research um
yeah so a little bit about me before uh
before we get started i'm
currently a research fellow at the
knowledge lab which is a lab here at the
university of chicago
i'm interested broadly in the philosophy
history and sociology of
ai and development um a little bit of
what i've done in the past i've uh
authored a book on nlp and computational
linguistics with python
i've published in cognition machine
learning research computational
linguistics and
related stuff um and i finished my
master's
in computational social science which is
what i'll be talking about from here at
the university of chicago
i'm a huge python nerd uh you know i've
been just doing this for
six seven years now uh i love the pi
data python community i've been you know
i've
i've met a lot of another speakers here
and a lot of
people who will be seeing this talk to
i'm sure uh
i miss you know being in person with you
all but
this is the next best thing so uh let's
uh let's do it
cool so i'm gonna you know just jump
right in with the
you know the obvious question what what
exactly is computational social science
now i mean easily at least one part of
the straight forward is it's
as you know it's in the name it's
computational approaches to social
science research
now let's you know let's break this into
two parts um
you know you can already see on my slide
what i'm gonna say but
basically when it comes to social
science research
there's a lot of social sciences right i
mean it's an academic discipline to
start with
um and commonly of course it really
depends on
the university or the country which
decides you know which
science is social science or natural
science but normally it's economics
psychology
sociology political science anthropology
and history
and you know sometimes like some people
throw philosophy there if that's
humanities or not but basically these
are usually
uh what you would normally call social
science and economics is largely
the study of economic systems so like
macroeconomics just like a whole country
and micro should be smaller firms
psychology is you know
the way we think and the way we react
the way our brain works the way we
do various things sociologies or social
relations political science studies uh
are political institutions uh
anthropology anthropo means human so
it's the study of human relations in
human history and you know
how humans behave in history as well you
know history so
uh this is again like a very very basic
kind of introduction right there's just
so much going on these are massive
fields with their own
histories they're like they're very old
fields
a lot of these are at least about 120
130 years old
and um yeah people people get phds and
all of these things
uh and more and so on and there's a lot
of of course real world applications
uh i mean they're all essentially real
world things
so uh yeah this is those are what so the
social sciences are
and as for where does the computational
part come in now
there's a variety of techniques a few of
them are you know text analysis
going through large bodies of text
psychology uh sorry
data scraping which is basically getting
data off the internet data wrangling
organizing your data
machine learning which is basically you
know predicting things and
you know is the pi data as i'm sure a
lot of you know that's going on over
there
a network analysis is analyzing graphs
or networks of connections
now so far i've just thrown a bunch of
like words just like a bunch of keywords
at you right now
let me give you a couple of examples on
like
what is possibly like economics
computational social science
uh one you know one thing which
immediately jumps to my mind is for
example say you're
working as part of a policy team right
and you want to see how
a new tax is going to have larger
effects on
uh the economy on people's lives what
you can do is you can come up with a
mathematical model of how maybe a tax
would work
and then use data and run a
computational
kind of simulation to see how would this
actually end up affecting people this is
an example of
a computationally powered approach to
social science research
you've had in the past you know you
might not have as much data or the
computational tools and it would be
either theoretical or just a
mathematical model but we can go beyond
that now
in psychology what we can do is we can
connect a large variety of experiments
especially
which are computational now in terms of
how do people make decisions in
different contexts
how do people's uh how do people work in
teams together
and like what kind of you know what kind
of result what kind of team setup
leads to different kinds of results and
analyzing these kinds of patterns
using you know uh techniques such as
just you know statistical techniques as
well with the large volunteer of our
packages
is also part of what computational
psychology research looks like
computational sociology research now
well i think this is one of the fields
which is really especially taken awful
i'm biased because i do most of my
research in that but
uh one one like popular thing which
people using right now is using data
from reddit or twitter
uh to mine kind of information see
political polarization or
um which is you know happening a lot
right now at least in india and the us
which are two countries which you know
i'm kind of
you know embedded in so
anthropology you look at you know human
relations with things for example how
have we
how is technology changed the way we
live our lives um
i mean i don't want to get started but
like smartphones and 10 years ago with
smartphones and right
it's just a crazy world out there so
just with their
technological paradigm the social
sciences are just transforming
very rapidly and uh this rapid
transformation
of the social sciences is really aided
by
python which is what like really blew my
mind as you know i was
i was a computer scientist before i
started entering into the social science
research and
it was uh it was the best possible
training i felt i could have had right
before jumping in
now i thought like you know so i've
given you like a very
kind of i've given you a very
basic kind of a lot of keywords being
thrown at you right
so i wanted to just give you a general
feel of what it kind of feels like you
know intuitively what these kind of
things would do
getting into real details i mean you'd
have to well you know pretty much google
it and find out on your own
but what we can do is i'm going to give
you one particular example of a project
which i was involved in
which is you know truly
interdisciplinary and sits between a lot
of the social sciences
and i think that'll give you an example
of
you know what exactly is possible with
the python
open source and computational social
science
so the project which i'm going to you
know use as an example to tell you what
this is
is called computational synesthesia or
what we call comp sin
for short uh so this project was you
know kind of thought up or
uh you know came about at the santa fe
institutes
which is in new mexico here in the us um
it's a beautiful place
uh the complex system summer school of
2019
where it was uh six scientists uh we
were a very interesting
team you know there's two social
scientists me included
a computer scientist an astrophysicist
cognitive scientist and a painter
an artist and um you know we were we
were interested in thinking about
synesthesia synesthesia is uh basically
it's when
it's a neurological trait when different
kinds of senses
are relate to each other in ways which
we don't normally so for example people
smell colors or they hear words
and when they hear words they don't just
hear a word they hear a certain musical
sound with it or they see colors along
with words and we
i'm you know my background is in uh
natural language processing and
computational linguistics we were
particularly interested in
the relationship between words and
colors now you can
you know of course the reason we started
thinking about this particular problem
is when we have like an artist in the
mix and astrophysicists job was to study
images and colors and we thought
well they could really be here or
something so the reason i'm you know
giving this setting is to kind of
motivate you in the sense of like how
does you know python or open source fit
into like a you know like a social
scientist thinking process right
now this work was just a bunch of us
hanging out and you know talking and now
this works been published in
leading venues and journals so it's
really cool to see it moving from
you know friends and colleagues talking
to
writing code to creating a social
scientific experiment and then just
going ahead with it uh i you can see the
github link over there
compson which is where we put all of our
code
so that's the uh that's the start and
i'm gonna you know
tell you exactly what's what's going on
how did we think of this
so what we thought of was we wanted to
see
when you think of a word let's let that
word be fear for example or happiness
these are just you know two emotions uh
there's a you know there's a there's a
feeling that some words have like an
obvious
kind of color attached to it right like
when you think of maybe um
i'm trying to think of something that's
always one color and i thought of apple
and grapes and i'm like well apples can
be red and green and grapes can be
purple and green as well so that's you
know
not maybe the best example let's say
orange you know oranges are normally
orange
so you know some things are concrete and
have a color
and some things are more difficult for
us to kind of
find a color associated with like for
example happiness or joy or
sadness these are abstract words where
normally we
it feels like we don't associate a color
with it but
is there a kind of global synesthesia or
even like
regional synesthesia where people
associate
certain colors with words for example um
you know you have like jealousy and envy
having the color green associated with
it you have sadness and blue
so there seems to be that despite things
not having a concrete representation
there does certain seem to be a color
associated with the word and we thought
you know we kind of have this intuition
behind this as six
you know interdisciplinary people how do
we use you know how do we just use
how do we con set up an social
scientific experiment right like
how do we how do we make this uh science
how do we move from our intuitions to
science
so what we thought of was let's just get
a bunch of
words associated with a bunch of images
so we just
used uh python's google search image
api to just so we'd search for a word
we get the top hundred images of that
word so for example
i'm going to go with the same happiness
uh fear sadness kind of
set up so we would search each of these
words so we'd search happiness we'd
search sadness
search whatever word is get 100 images
and now when we get images in you know
computer format it's what it's rgb
right um that's we just basically have
pixels and you know
pixels on and spatial arrangement now
when humans look at something we don't
think of you know like this color we
don't look at this as oh that has 300
pixels of this or whatever and you know
it's arranged in this space so we kind
of we perceive the colors in a different
way
so what we did was we basically got
the rgb distribution of each of the
hundred words associate 100 images
associated with the word
convert this rgb representation into a
representation called
jzazbz which is just you know the name
of
this human perceptible color schema
which is done in this 2017 paper where
these color scientists basically look a
word and there's more to a word than
just you know
the percentage of the different kinds of
colors up here and there's like this hue
and saturation
and of course the color itself but it's
a little more nuanced in that the way we
humans perceive it as different
so we basically took these you know more
human perceptible
color distributions so we got we get
this massive numpy array of all these
rgbs
transform it just using a basic you know
like a
array matrix transformation into this
human perceptible color scheme
average all of these hundred images for
each word
and boom we now have like a simple
vector like a distribution of human
perceptible colors for each
word so again like happiness i'm gonna
okay i'm gonna go to the next slide
because you're gonna see you know
exactly what's going on it's really neat
so here uh so i'm gonna okay the example
you know probably should ship to this
example because it's the one in the
images
but it's a similar kind of paradigm we
tried to you know so we did this for a
couple of different um
disciplines we did for academic
disciplines and also emotions so i'm
gonna
switch our example to disciplines over
here
but it's basically the same setup as you
can see so we get use word net which is
again like uh
it's a standard it's in natural language
processing and computational linguistics
it's basically we used to get
hierarchies of words
uh we get hierarchies of words like this
and then after that we
collect the top hundred google image
searches create the distributions and
cluster it
and the crazy thing was we found out
that even abstract semantic domains what
i mean by abstract semantic domains is
emotions or
academic disciplines or music genres
which is what we do it on
uh you would still have strong
clustering you know even for abstract
concepts i mean you'd expect like
grapes and apples and oranges and
mangoes to maybe cluster together
because these are
more associated with one color but to
have even
abstract semantic domains significantly
clustered
this was um this is like something which
we
couldn't possibly have done before and
you know
just with the power of like python's
google image search api a couple of
numpy matrix uh you know transformations
dictionaries to store all of these
things uh
scipy also has really great like
probability like entropy matchers and
maybe those are worked in that kind of
field to know what i'm talking about
just measure these entropies so these
are simple
you know scientific computing all stuff
which num focus you know supports
basic scientific computing packages with
a simple we so we had a simple question
like do people associate colors with
words
and boom from there like in just two
days of like sitting together and just
programming is really hacky code before
as you know first trials are always
super hacky
so we got hacky code and then we were
like this is really neat we're seeing
like
abstract again we're just gonna go back
to this um
we're seeing abstract uh
concepts cluster we see like a blue
physics and a kind of yellow history and
yellow like literature and law and
anthropology and
this is really remarkable to us and we
scaled this up and we created 40 000
color vectors
and uh and then we released them and now
there's like
40 000 color vectors for people to play
around with and this was
like it's you can go and check the code
out in you know uh github.com
thompson thompson which i have posted
before it's really it's fairly
straightforward code
you know it isn't anything magical but
it was
a bunch of different num focus uh you
know
open source tools like just jammed
together and boom we
could uh you know do social science
research and for me that was this is
just you know
a kind of example of how python
and you know open source research just
comes together to
to create something really cool now
you know i like to i started with that
example you know
i wanted to start with that example
because i think it gives you a direct
example of how
you can do really
large scale because you know we've also
what we're doing right now is we're kind
of taking that research a little ahead
by having um like location data as well
location and temporal data to see
are these synesthetic associations of
words constant
they evolve over time and again simple
python code is how we're doing all of
this
after we made it open source and you
know release it on twitter you had a
bunch of other sociologists cognitive
scientists anthropologists of color
historians all coming and reaching out
to us being like wow that's
this is so cool and you know how do we
use your tool and then
it's just it's wonderful like the
community
uh is quick to adapt i'm going to show
you my note but you know basically it's
move the move from people using tools
like you know
this sas or matlab uh which is also more
like natural science oriented a little
more like old-fashioned
to you know that move from there to
python being really taking off i think
would be around
2014-15 was when it kind of really took
off to hit the
social sciences and the way it has now i
mean you know some social so in the past
we'd have
maybe some social scientists who would
be like okay i'm a
computational social scientist but now
you just have
so many you have i mean my master's the
master's program which i uh graduated
from is just one example of this
but you have this across um again
uh i'm speaking specifically for the us
right now but
i have a lot of colleagues in europe
where i know cologne for example is one
center of a place where
a lot of this is going on that really
great computational social science group
but basically you just have a lot more
social scientists all over the world
whether it's psychology so they're
thinking
oh how do i just set up a law you know a
lot of experiments collect the data and
then run quick analysis it's on a
jupyter notebook that's how you're doing
it
how do i find out how political
polarization how twitter has maybe
contributed to that just do a network
analysis of see
who's retweeting who and then you follow
these networks and you start this are
there certain cliques
are there certain kinds of people who
are tweeting certain kinds of things
uh another bunch of research was done
with um
amazon books to basically see are you
know
i know in america the liberal
conservative divide is kind of
a little crazy because uh you know we
only have real two parties over here as
opposed to europe it's a little
so crit you know i don't want to get
into that now possibly but basically
a lot of really cool studies on
polarization
uh which you can do using uh data from
amazon and twitter basically see who's
buying what kind of books and
all these open source tools like
beautiful soup for example for scraping
websites has been really popular
and now why is this you know becoming so
important so necessary right now um
there's been what you know
social scientists call a reproducibility
crisis uh
especially in biomedical sciences and
psychology where
you know people would run these
experiments um you know offline on
very homogeneous groups largely would be
just college students
maybe male usually white and it was
basically the kind of you know social
science is supposed to be more generic
and more
um it should generalize to larger
populations and this couldn't happen and
a lot of the psychology studies being
you know done in the past and medical
studies being done in the past is
we're not reproducible right now
political science studies as well and
this was a you know failure on um just
from a philosophical perspective on what
science should be able to do
now now the awesome awesome thing right
now is
you have data sets which are open you
have people you know
people making all of their code open as
well so you have suddenly you have an
increase in
open science and and for me what you
know really really special part of this
and something's right here to me is like
teaching it and i think that
there's just a huge proliferation of
jupiter notebooks on github and
it was incredible for me when like i
know i started a master's in social
sciences and one of the things i was
taught was
git and i was like wow you know this is
where we come this is something which i
i thought i mean i'm a computer nerd so
i thought it was really cool but and
even though some of my you know some of
the classmates are initially struggling
i see that like
after one or two years of learning these
tools they're like i i can't even do my
social science research the way it was
done before
um it's really paradigm shifting and
it's
it's something which again i see with my
colleagues and professors and people
moving on to these tools and
of course they have older folks or maybe
not who don't trust it as much right now
but
that's changing and um i think it's
really incredible with more data more
tools
more teaching resources just more people
doing these things you have
you know interpretable and reproducible
science for me that's very special
and um you know another easy way to just
look at this is check out like just uh
look at all the pythons and pi datas
and you have just so many more social
science
oriented kind of tutorials even if it's
not very obvious on the first
because it's so used a lot in industry
and different like in all these network
analysis all a lot of the things which i
talked about right now
aren't just publications or uh
research projects stuck in dusty
universities it's you know
it's very interpretable to like business
largely a lot of companies use a lot of
these ideas and tools for their
you know in-house data analysis we've
been consulting a lot of these things so
it's uh again i'm looking at this from a
more academic perspective so it's a
little
i'm looking from the perspective of
teaching and you know reproducible
science and
you know from that perspective of course
this is uh i'm sure all of you who have
you know
worked in a data-oriented position have
or kind of get about the things which
i'm talking about
now i you know i briefly wanted to do
this because it seems
it seems almost uh not responsible
to not have us just a little bit about
this but um
so for us computational social
scientists our work is
necessarily socially situated now
there's a
common mistake which people do and i
don't want to rag on physicists for this
but like usually
you know a lot of people tend to think
that science is not political
that science is not social but science
is inherently political and inherently
social
knowledge is social and political what
we decide to be true and what we decide
to not be true and what we decide to
research and what we decide to not
research
are all political and social um
actions and decisions and it's very
important for
you know this is kind of a call to other
social scientists and
also those who might be interested in
starting to remind you all that our work
is
has very important uh consequences
um i don't know if you've seen you know
the documentary social dilemma which
came up on netflix to see how
a lot of social media companies are
essentially
you know where as long as money as long
as our
reasons for doing science is profit
oriented i think it'll be problematic
and as if you don't think about class
race sexuality and you know
other intrinsic properties in our data
and how what we're exactly trying to
measure it's going to be very
problematic
there's a you know a lot of books a lot
of um
please like reach out i'm happy to chat
about this i honestly think i think
there's
a lot of talks on just about the you
know ethics of data
um so i won't be diving into that but
it's again
i reminders you know we can get carried
away that oh wow i've demonstrated that
happiness has a color and then you know
you shouldn't get carried away by um
by the things you can do with these kind
of tools which we have and kind of
realize the philosophical
responsibilities which uh scientists
have
now uh just for those who might want to
start doing these things again i feel
like a lot of information here right i
just kind of threw a lot of words at you
and ran through a lot
uh i would really check out uh si css
which is a
you know school for its computational
social science book a lot of videos
videos tutorials and code um
about a week or two ago i gave a
tutorial at pycon india
on computational social science of
python uh
you know it includes kind of gives you a
lot of some of the things which i talked
about
you know introduces those concepts uh
particularly focusing on text and
network analysis
basic basic python stuff just like
network x spacey jensen
uh kind of you know very uh basic but
you can do a lot with it you can do a
lot of like real social scientific
analysis
so i'm just throwing that link in there
uh um
and you know like there's a lot of text
symmetrical so you can just
walk through it and you'd be able to
figure it out um
i would highly recommend just checking
it out there's a really cool world out
there of
um you know easily mindable data and
experiments you can set up
uh and check out and uh yeah
um well thank you uh my so you know that
bargavator is my uh you know twitter
handle
uh instagram handle gmail like pretty
much everything github as well of course
um please reach out to me uh i love to
chat about this
i would love to give resources and other
kinds of tools um
kind of you know yeah i just wanted to
do this talk to
to tell people about because i wasn't
sure if you know those are working in
kind of uh
the non-academic kind of part of you
know data-oriented python stuff know
about
the things that social scientists are
doing or what even social sciences are
um they so yeah this is a kind of
hurried overall brief talk about it
uh but there's just so much to see and
do of course you know you only ever
really learn from actually doing the
code check out the tutorials uh check
out thompson
uh to see you know how exactly we do
what we do
and uh yeah thank you thank you all very
much